comp les républicains et pour deux
minutes monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
l'heure est au bilan ce que l'on
retiendra de ce quinquennat c'est que
malgré des discours qui ont l'apparence
de la générosité
à force de renoncements et d'entêtement
ce gouvernement est responsable d'une
casse sociale sans précédent
une politique se juge à l'aune de ces
résultats il ne se juge pas à l'aune
d'une vision de la société qui tourne le
dos à la réalité
quel est le vrai bilan de la gauche
depuis 2012 le chômage a explosé
nous sommes passés du 14e au 22e rang en
europe
notre école est parmi les plus
inégalitaires l'abandon de nos campagnes
à créer des zones en totale des
élections
enfin l'autorité de l'état vacillante a
laissé se développer ce que l'on appelle
pudiquement des zones de non droit
derrière le chômage qui a explosé
derrière l'école qui ne remplit pas sa
mission
derrière des territoires abandonnés
derrière la violence et la délinquance
nous réprimer il y à des français qui
souffrent et pour qui ce quinquennat
illustre ce qu'est la casse sociale
votre politique produit ses pires effets
sur les plus faibles ce sont les plus
faibles qui sont au chômage qui décroche
à l'école qui vivent dans nos régions
abandonné qui subissent la violence au
quotidien
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre qu'il est temps que vous
regardiez les faits en face l'heure
n'est-elle pas venu de vous poser la
question de l'échec de tous ses choix
depuis cinq ans pour vous répondre la
parole à monsieur le premier ministre
sur le monsieur le sénateur je pense
qu'il n'a pas dû échapper à votre
sagacité que nous étions dans une
période électorale pour poser une
question aussi nuancé
vraiment nous étions depuis le début de
cette séance au sénat dans la recherche
du rassemblement et de la mesure
je sentais bien que pour un certain
nombre d'entre vous une minorité cela
constitue un effort sur eux-mêmes
extrêmement importants dont je ne savais
pas s'il pourrait aller jusqu'au terme
de la séance et votre question
immédiatement nous ramène à la réalité
de ce qu'est la politique dans ces
affrontements les plus classiques
bon moi je suis je suis face à la
réalité à laquelle notre pays est
confronté
par souci de donner tes dans la
démonstration par souci aussi de vérité
dans une exigence de pondération et d'
équilibre certes il est possible que
nous n'ayons pas tout réussi mais de là
à considérer comme le sous-entend votre
question que nous aurions tout raté il y
à la frontière qui sépare la bonne foi
de la mauvaise foi et je voudrais
reprendre un certain nombre d'exemples
vous inquiétez de l'école mais pourquoi
est ce que ne vous est pas inquiété de
l'école lorsque 80 mille emplois dans
les cols étaient supprimées que la
formation des enseignants étaient
remises en cause que les échecs
scolaires en résulter et pourquoi est ce
que vous ne considérez pas comme
d'ailleurs contrairement à l'idée que
vous allez laisser penser pourquoi
est-ce que vous ne reconnaissez pas
comme l' enquête pisa que le fait que
nous ayons recréer des postes que nous
aurions redonner des moyens permettent
aujourd'hui à des zones qui étaient très
défavorisé par exemple comme la
seine-saint-denis de retrouver des
emplois d'enseignants parce qu'on pourra
dire ce que l'on veut si l'on veut
lutter efficacement contre l'échec
scolaire
il faut donner la possibilité à ceux qui
ont peu d'avoir plus avec des
enseignants est davantage d'enseignants
dans le face à face pédagogique de
manière à ce que l'égalité des chances
puisse être reconstitué lorsqu'il vous
parlais de l'école j'ai envie de vous
rappeler xp votre bilan ce qui a été
notre action et de faire ainsi la
différence
vous parlez de l'autorité de l'état et
vous parlez de la sécurité mais pourquoi
est ce que vous ne vous réjouissez pas
monsieur le sénateur de voir ce
gouvernement crée 9000 emplois là où la
majorité vous souteniez en a supprimé 13
milles ce serait un signe de netteté
intellectuelle au moment où nous
abordons ce débat pour
les élections présidentielles pourquoi
est-ce que vous ne reconnaissez pas que
grâce aux moyens que nous avons mobilisé
pour la sécurité et en mettant des
forces de sécurité là où il n'y en avait
pas nous avons pu par exemple dans votre
département
procéder dans des conditions totalement
humaine auquel d'ailleurs une partie de
vos amis politiques ne nous inviter pas
à évacuer
calé dans des conditions absolument
exemplaire que d'ailleurs en place
reconnaissent et que vous auriez pu
évoquer comme une réussite de ce
gouvernement dans la question vous avez
posée pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
reconnaissez pas que lorsque nous
mettons en place des dispositifs
destinés à reconstituer la compétitivité
des entreprises
au point que nos entreprises ont gagné
deux points de marge et retrouver leurs
marges d'avant la crise
d'avant la crise économique du milieu
des années 2000 pourquoi est-ce que vous
ne reconnaissez pas que cette politique
a permis aujourd'hui à l'investissement
industriel de connaître une progression
de 3,4 pour cent
c'est à dire une profession bien plus
importante qu'au cours des dernières
années donc je pourrais comme cela
monsieur le sénateur multiplier les
exemples égrainé les éléments mais je
comprends que cela vous contrarie
beaucoup et comme je suis là je n'ai pas
vocation à contrarier l'opposition je
m'arrêterai là d'une manière être agacé
votre soirée
monsieur rappaz monsieur le premier
ministre moi non plus je ne suis pas
contrarier jeu
le seul point monsieur le premier
ministre m'a non plus jeunes sup
[Applaudissements]
ben quoi
je suis désolé pour monsieur roux
simplement ne sera pas monsieur rappaz
et vous seul heureux pour vous monsieur
le premier ministre de savoir que vous
avez encore un auditoire vers moi les
biens néanmoins néanmoins vous dites
vous dit souvent qu'il faut réformer
sans détruire
je pense que vous avez détruit sans
réformer merci la parole est à notre
collègue